this is Wesley a Patagonian Mara he  looks like a cross between a deer and a  rabbit but Wesley is actually a rodent  Patagonian Mara's are only found in  parts of Central and South Argentina and  even there they are becoming harder to  spot these cute little guys top out at  just under three feet and just over 30  pounds  their bodies are well adapted for  running and they reach close to 45 miles  per hour at full speed  grass makes up the majority of this  herbivores diet they prefer living in  areas with lots of shrub cover to  protect themselves from predators  however a combination of over grazing  and hunting for their skin has caused a  steady decline in their population this  is the Patagonian Mara  you